now israeli prime minister benjamin
netanyahu has declared tomorrow a day of
mourning there in israel
this follows a stampede at a religious
festival that killed at least 45 people
but there's growing anger now over the
way security was handled at the festival
and safety warnings for large crowds
stretching back years which appear to
have been
ignored ariane lee is in our london
bureau with more on this ian good
morning
good morning errol we have learned from
israeli officials that at least
four americans were among those killed
and injured the u.s embassy is still
working with local officials to verify
if any other americans were affected
this all comes as israel mourns one of
the country's
deadliest civilian disasters
there were prayers and tears as families
buried their loved ones
[Music]
only hours earlier they were celebrating
an all-night festival of dancing
and bonfires this video captures the
moments before the deadly stampede
a narrow walkway where a huge crowd of
ultra-orthodox jews were heading for the
exit
men began to slip and the chaos did the
rest
paramedics and police struggled to pull
survivors to safety
just you heard a lot of people screaming
and a lot of people tried to run to see
what it was
you know and then they started carrying
bodies out on stretchers
this young man describes being pinned
under several people
it's a miracle i survived he says but
the night keeps replaying in my head
in the aftermath personal items still
littered the ground
mourners gather to search for their
loved ones belongings
and answers some are blaming the police
saying they blocked off an important
side street
causing a deadly traffic jam about a
hundred thousand people had gathered for
the annual celebration honoring a second
century rabbi and mystic
believed to be buried in northern israel
prime minister benjamin netanyahu
visited the site
calling the disaster a great tragedy and
promising a thorough investigation to
make sure
nothing like this happens again minister
netanyahu also said he spoke with
president biden yesterday who expressed
his condolences and sorrow
over what had happened dana you see that
narrow walkway ian it looks like a
disaster waiting to happen very sad
thank you for the report